- [Narrator] This is a
photo of Gregor Mendel,
who is often known as
the father of genetics.
And we'll see in a few seconds why,
and he was an Abbot of
a monastery in Moravia,
which is in modern day Czech Republic.
And many people had bred plants
for agricultural purposes
for hundreds, if not thousands
of years before Mendel,
but he really gave us a
glimpse, gave us insights
in how traits are really passed.
And he did this through
his pea plant experiments
that he conducted from 1856 to 1863.
Over that time period, he
bred roughly 28,000 pea plants
in order to get a better understanding
of how they passed down different traits.
And he studied things like
properties of the seeds,
properties of the pea prods,
and things like the height of the plant.
And in his time, the mainstream theory
was that if you bred a tall
parent with a short parent,
you would get a medium offspring,
but that's not what Mendel saw.
When he bred tall pea plants
with short pea plants,
all of the offspring were tall.
But then when he self
fertilized those plants
and plants have the interesting property
that they can fertilize themselves.
So the same plant can contribute
both the female gamete
and the male gametes.
In other words the same plant can be both
the female parent and the male parent.
Well, then he saw that
roughly there was a ratio
of three to one, tall to short.
Those weren't the exact numbers,
but pretty close to three to one.
And so there's a lot of really
interesting things here.
First of all, at least for this trait,
he didn't see any blending occur.
And then the other thing is,
this short trait reappeared
in this second generation.
In order to explain these
results, he hypothesized
that there are inheritable factors
that are inherited from
an organism's parents
and they're related to a specific trait.
So in this case it would be around height.
Now we know what he called
these inheritable factors.
We now call genes, although
he did not use the term,
and he also hypothesized
that these factors
could come in different versions.
Now, today we know that the
different versions of a gene,
we call alleles, although
he did not use that term,
but in this case, the versions
that we have at our disposal,
you could have a tall height,
which we can shorthand say,
capital T, capital T for tall,
or you could have a short height,
which I will use lowercase
t for, for a short height.
Now generally speaking,
organisms will have two versions
of their genes like this.
For example, an organism
could have two tall alleles,
or two short, or one of each,
but when it produces its
gametes, the sex cells,
so the sperm for a male
and the egg for a female,
it will generally contribute
one of its two versions
to its offspring.
And this contribution of
one allele or the other
is known as Mendel's law of segregation.
And we can draw, what's
known as a Punnett square
to depict this.
So let me draw a little
bit of a grid here.
And Mendel actually did not
invent the Punnett square,
although he was thinking in these terms.
It was actually invented by
Reginald Punnett in 1905.
And this is useful to think
about the probabilities
of various combinations based on what
each parent could contribute.
So let's say we're talking
about the tall plant,
and let's say it has two tall versions.
So it can contribute a
capital T or a capital T.
And let's say that this
short plant over here
has two of the short versions for now.
So it could contribute
either a lowercase t,
or a lowercase t.
And so what are all the
possible combinations
for its offspring?
Well, in one scenario, you
could get this capital T
from the male parent,
and this lowercase t,
from the female parent.
In another scenario, you
could get this capital T
from the male parent, and a lowercase t
from the female parent.
In this scenario, and I know
these look very similar,
a capital T from the male
parent and this lowercase t
from the female parent, and
then last but not least,
I know this looks repetitive,
you could get this capital T
from the male parent and this lowercase t
from the female parent.
And the reason why in all of these cases,
you see a tall plant, is
because the tall version,
and he coined this term, is dominant.
And once again, this
was all his hypothesis
to explain his results.
So this is dominant and
the short is recessive.
So even if you have one of each,
you're actually going to
show the dominant trait.
We now call that your phenotype,
what you show is going to be tall.
Now, what's interesting
about this hypothesis
is it seems to explain what
happens in the next generation.
Just so a little bit of notation.
The first generation is usually called
the P generation for parental,
and then the first generation of offspring
is known as the F1, F for filial.
And that comes filials,
which means sun in Greek,
and then the generation
after that would be F2,
that's just a little
bit of notation there,
but let's think about what would happen
at the F2 generation,
if you self fertilized,
some of these characters right over here.
Well, in that situation, let
me draw another Punnett square,
on the male parents side,
you could contribute
either your capital T version,
which we now call your dominant allele,
or you could contribute
the lowercase t version,
and on the female parents side
and once again for a plant,
you can have the same plant
that has both the male
and the female parent.
You could contribute the
dominant version, the capital T,
or the recessive version, the lowercase t.
Now we see something interesting
happen in the offspring.
There is a one in four chance
you get both capital Ts.
So capital T, capital T.
There's also a one in four
chance that you get a lowercase t
from the male parent up here,
and then you get a capital T
from the female parent.
There is another one in four
chance you get a capital T
from the male parent, and a lowercase t
from the female parent.
And then there's a one in four chance
that you get two lowercase ts,
one each from the male and female parent.
Now, if we accept the dominant
and recessive hypothesis,
we would expect that plants
that got both capital Ts
would be tall, but we would
also expect that these over here
would be tall as well, because
the capital T is dominant.
They would exhibit the tall phenotype.
And then you would
expect probabilistically
that one fourth of your plants
over time, would be short
because they only have
the recessive alleles,
the recessive traits in this situation.
And that's actually what Mendel saw.
Now what's amazing is that Mendel was able
to figure this out without
knowing about chromosomes,
without knowing all that we know today.
Today we know this works because we have
23 pair of chromosomes, and
each of those pairs have copies,
have different versions
of usually the same gene,
and that when meiosis occurs
and you have gamete formation,
one member of each pair
will segregate randomly
into the newly formed sex cell,
into the sperm or the egg.
That's why this occur and we
go into some detail on that
in other videos, but it's pretty cool,
that Mendel was able to figure
this out in the 19th century.